The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DR. BOGDAN FEDELES: Hello, and
welcome to 5.07 Biochemistry
online.
I'm Dr. Bogdan Fedeles.
Let's metabolize some problems.
Today we're discussing
problem 2 of problem set 6.
Here we're going to
explore in more detail
the mechanism of
phosphoglycerate mutase, which
is the eighth enzyme
in glycolysis.
It's the enzyme that
catalyzes the conversion
of 3-phosphoglycerate
to 2-phosphoglycerate.
Generally speaking,
mutases are enzymes
that catalyze the
shift of a functional
group between two similar
positions of a molecule.
In the case of
phosphoglycerate mutase,
this enzyme catalyzes
the transfer
of the phosphate group from
the 3 position of glycerate
to the 2 position of glycerate.
In 5.07, you will
encounter several mutases.
Similar to
phosphoglycerate mutase,
there is a
bisphosphoglycerate mutase,
which converts
1,3-bisphosphoglycerate
to 2,3-bisphosphoglycerate.
Now, this reaction
is very important
when it happens in
the red blood cells.
Another mutase
you will encounter
is in the glycogen
breakdown pathway.
It's called phosphoglucomutase
and converts
glucose 1-phosphate to
glucose 6-phosphate.
Now finally, the most
intriguing of them
all is the
methylmalonyl-coa mutase,
which is a fascinating enzyme
that converts methylmalonyl-coA
to succinyl-coA.
In this reaction, it
rearranges this carbon skeleton
of the molecule, and it
requires adenosylcobalamin,
which is a co-factor
derived from vitamin B12.
Back to phosphoglycerate mutase,
this is a fascinating enzyme
because it uses a phosphorylated
histidine in the active site.
And this is actually an example
of a phosphorous-nitrogen bond,
one of the very few
available in biochemistry.
Here is a schematic
of the mechanism
of phosphoglycerate mutase.
Now, the reaction
starts where the enzyme
is already phosphorylated.
We'll call it a phospho enzyme.
And the histidine
in the active site
contains the phosphate group.
Then the enzyme binds the
substrate 3-phosphoglycerate.
And then it's going to transfer
this phosphate group onto the 2
position, the 2-hydroxyl of the
3-phosphoglycerate to generate
the 2,3-bisphosphoglycerate.
Then the phosphate
at the 3 position
is transferred to the
histidine to generate
the product of the
reaction 2-phosphoglycerate
and regenerate
the phosphoenzyme.
Note that the phosphate group
is in fact not transferred.
This phosphate group
here is not the same
that ends up on the 2 position.
But rather, this phosphate group
gets transferred to the enzyme.
And the phosphate
group from the enzyme
ends up on the second
position of glycerate.
As we just mentioned, the
active form of the enzyme
has already the phosphate
bound to histidine.
Now the question is, how
did this phosphate get there
in the first place?
Presumably, the enzyme is
first synthesized in a form
that we call apo form, which
does not have the phosphate.
And the phosphate is then
added as a post-translational
modification.
Now, our problem suggests that
one source for this phosphate
is phosphoenolpyruvate.
And there's some
experimental evidence
that phosphoenolpyruvate
can transfer their phosphate
and phosphorylate the
histidine in this enzyme.
Now, we are asked
to comment on how
reasonable this proposal is.
We're going to evaluate
the proposed transformation
between phosphoenolpyruvate
and phosphoglycerate mutase
from two points of view.
First of all, is
this transformation
thermodynamically accessible?
And second, is this
structurally feasible?
We know that
phosphoenolpyruvate contains
a high-energy
phosphate bond that
can release a lot of
energy upon hydrolysis.
Now, if we look
in our book, this
is the Voet & Voet,
Third Edition.
If we look here,
phosphoenolpyruvate,
it says, releases about
62 kilojoules per mole
upon hydrolysis.
Now this is significantly
more than what
energy is released by
the hydrolysis of ATP
going to ADP, which is only
about 31 kilojoules per mole.
Now, this should not
be surprising to you
because PEP,
phosphoenolpyruvate,
is used in the last
step of glycolysis,
the pyruvate kinase, to
phosphorylate ADP and generate
ATP.
So the fact it has a higher
energy of hydrolysis,
it just makes that
transformation
thermodynamically accessible.
Let's now take a look at
the arrow pushing mechanism
of how phosphoenolpyruvate
can phosphorylate
phosphoglycerate mutase.
Here is the
phosphoenolpyruvate molecule,
and here is the histidine in
the active site of the enzyme.
Now, as you know, histidine
has a pKa of about 6,
so an important fraction
of the histidine
will be protonated
at physiological pH.
However, for this
reaction to work
we need the histidine
to act as a nucleophile
to attack the phosphate.
Therefore, we're going to
consider it deprotonated.
Now, the reaction
starts by assuming
there's a base in the
active site that's
going to deprotonate
the histidine,
and then it's going to
attack the phosphate.
And finally, the
phosphate group is
going to leave with the
assistance of a general acid.
So these are the
products that we obtain.
This is the phosphoenzyme with
the histidine that now has
the phosphate group attached.
And this is the enol
that is released
from the
phosphoenolpyruvate, which is
the enol form of the pyruvate.
Now, if we evaluate the starting
material and the product
in terms of their
ability to stabilize
negative charge, such as the
charges on the phosphate,
by resonance--
We notice that there is
no significant difference.
Here we have two negative
charges and one set
of phosphorus oxygen bonded.
The charge can delocalize
on this oxygen.
We also have this carboxylate
group, which we also have here.
So there's not a lot of resonant
stabilization between starting
materials and products so far.
Therefore, this reaction
is thermodynamically
close to neutral.
However, notice the
enol form of pyruvate.
Now this is in fact a
very unstable product.
And it likes to
tautomerize, basically
isomerize in acid
base conditions
to the keto form of a pyruvate.
The mechanism would
be, as such, the base
can deprotonate the enol.
And then, the general acid
can protonate CH2 group
to generate the keto
form of the pyruvate.
It turns out the delta G
for this transformation
is very negative.
Delta G here is approximately
minus 40 kilojoules per mole.
So that means this reaction is
strongly going to the right,
and strongly favors
the keto form.
So that means per ensemble the
transformation going from PEP
in our histidine
in the active site
is going to be strongly
driven to the right because
of this keto equilibrium.
Therefore, the entire
process shown here
is expected to be
thermodynamically very
favorable.
Now let's take a look at some
structural considerations.
In order for PEP to
phosporylate the enzyme,
it has to be able to
reach the histidine that's
deep in the active site.
Notice that the
2-phosphoglycerate
is one of the products or
substrates of the enzyme.
And therefore, it fits very
nicely in the active site.
Now phosphoenolpyruvate looks
a lot like 2-phosphoglycerate.
Going to sketch it here, going
to have the phosphate there,
and then there's the double
bond in this position.
So because
phosphoenolpyruvate looks
a lot like 2-phosphoglycerate it
should have no problem fitting
inside the active
site of the enzyme
and reaching the
active site histidine.
Therefore, the chemical reaction
proposed in this problem
is quite reasonable.
First of all, the
thermodynamics are
excellent because the hydrolysis
of phosphoenolpyruvate
gives a lot of energy.
And then the sterics are
also favorable because PEP
resembles
2-phosphoglycerate, one
of the products of the enzyme.
Part 2 of this problem asks us
to evaluate the consequences
on the major function of
glycolysis of this reaction
that we just discussed--
of phosphoenolpyruvate
with phosphoglycerate mutase.
Here is the second
half of glycolysis,
going from glyceraldehyde
phosphate, or GAP, all the way
to pyruvate.
As you know, the main
function of glycolysis
is to generate ATP.
And for each
molecule of glucose,
we have a net generation
of two molecules of ATP.
Now, ATP is produced
in two places.
First, at the
phosphoglycerate kinase when
1,3-bisphosphoglycerate can
phosphorylate ADP to generate
ATP.
And then the
pyruvate kinase where
phosphoenolpyruvate
phosphorylates
ADP to generate ATP.
Now since we start glycolysis
by investing some ATP,
we need two molecules of ATP
to phosphorylate glucose.
We recover those
two molecules of ATP
at the phosphoglycerate
kinase step.
So all the net production of
ATP that we get in glycolysis
comes from the pyruvate
kinase reaction shown here.
Now, if
phosphoenolpyruvate is used
to phosphorylate
phosphoglycerate mutase,
basically, it's going
to react to give
the phosphate group here.
It's going to generate pyruvate
but without generating ATP,
right?
So the phosphate group goes to
this phosphoglycerate mutase,
and it generates
pyruvate, but we
get no net production of ATP.
Now if PEP is used
to phosphorylate
phosphoglycerate
mutase, it's not
going to be available for
the pyruvate kinase step.
But we do generate pyruvate,
so the whole transformation
reaches pyruvate, but without
producing a net amount of ATP.
Of course, this should not
be a significant problem,
as in glycolysis we
only require the enzymes
in catalytic amounts.
So initially, we're not going to
be generating net amount of ATP
until we phosphorylate
the entire pool
of phosphoglycerate mutase.
After that, now we have
phosphoglycerate mutase,
so PEP is once again available
for the pyruvate kinase
reaction to generate ATP.
I hope you noticed that there
is a more subtle question here.
If we're going to use
PEP to phosphorylate
phosphoglycerate
mutase, how are we
going to get to produce
PEP in the first place
since we need
phosphoglycerate mutase to go
from 3-phosphoglycerate
to 2-phosphoglycerate,
which then produces PEP.
Again, it's kind of like one
of these chicken and the egg
problems.
As you'll find
out, many pathways
feed into or intersect
with glycolysis.
And therefore,
phosphoenolpyruvate
could in principle be
made in other ways.
For example, in
gluconeogenesis you'll
see that pyruvate can lead
to oxaloacetate, which then
can lead to phosphoenolpyruvate
using this enzyme called
PEP carboxykinase, or PEPCK.
So there are ways to produce
phosphoenolpyruvate, which
can then, say, phosphorylate
phosphoglycerate mutase, which
then allows the glycolysis to
flow through in the normal way.
Well, that's it
for this problem.
I hope you found
pretty intriguing how
phosphoglycerate mutase works.
Now remember, this is one
of the very few enzymes
in biochemistry that utilizes
the phosphorylated histidine.
And this is one of
the few examples
of a phosphorus-nitrogen
bond we have in biochemistry.
Also remember, the
phosphoenolpyruvate
is the highest high-energy
phosphate compound
we have in the body.
But all that hydrolysis
energy really
comes from the keto
enol tautomerization
equilibrium of the pyruvate that
gets released upon hydrolysis.